hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to add and remove gadgets from your
windows vista sidebar here's my sidebar
it's got a few new gadgets in it and i
also have the battery indicator over
here what i'm going to show you today is
how obviously in hd to add and remove
gadgets so first you'll notice at the
top there is a small little
plus button hit that plus button
and there's a number of gadgets already
built in to the windows vista sidebar
that come with it such as stocks and
feed headlines that i haven't actually
put in my sidebar yet
these you can drag in easily simply by
clicking holding them and dragging them
to any place in the sidebar letting go
and they're instantly in there i had
this one before so there's already a few
contacts
and exit this one out
but you've always wondered well i've
seen people with these cool
these things or maybe a weather one or a
cpu usage ram usage monitor
wondering how to get one of those so so
you simply hit the button hit get more
gadgets online
this will open your default web browser
might happen to be safari right now
and it'll visit the windows website
where you can search for more gadgets
so
there's top rated gadgets there are top
down gadgets i'm going to show you an
example of how to
insert a gadget so say you want to get
the vista calculator over here in the
bottom of your sidebar or say right
between the google one and the stock
gadget
what you do
first i will click on it
and it'll open up its webpage it'll tell
you all about it usually and you have to
make sure it's free unless you want to
actually buy it
so you hit the download button
this will take you straight to the
download page and begin your download so
give it a second
and it'll say read carefully
um only install applications from
developers you trust hit my install
button here and open
and up here it's done downloading it's a
tiny file i'm going to open it up and
install
so
you can see it's already there
now i'm going to exit out of my web
browser and everything since this is no
longer necessary
and you'll also notice it says page one
of two you don't see this the calculator
here
in here actually you do it's right there
but once you get a certain amount of
gadgets you can actually move to your
second page and the second page of
gadgets which is just my xm radio
so i'm gonna exit out of this
so here's the new gadget that's as
simple as that you can grab this little
grid thing here and remove it and maybe
insert it somewhere else where i where
you wanted it before
and there we go
so that is how you get the windows
vistas
gadgets
from microsoft itself into your sidebar
if i want to delete it or maybe change
options the wrench always means options
so if i were to exit this out and go in
here and hit the wrench since this is
the weather gadget i can change from
fahrenheit to celsius i can enter my
location etc
that's what the wrench always means and
i'll try to zoom in on the wrench for
you
so here is the wrench right there i
don't know if you can see that it's all
the way on the edge but
that's the wrench always means settings
so
and removing like i said is as easy as
exiting out and if you go into the plus
again that brings it up right click one
and hit uninstall
to remove it completely from your
computer
and that's as easy as it is
and i think it'll there it is it's gone
pga tour one is gone and i only have one
page because xm radio is back on the
first page
so that is how you install and uninstall
gadgets from your sidebar should you be
using one in windows vista
so um there's a lot of cool gadgets here
so if i was to search blah and just hit
enter it'll open up a web browser google
search blah and bam i'm already
searching it so
there's a lot of useful gadgets that i
would recommend if you have a powerful
enough computer and if you have enough
random access memory to actually do this
kind of stuff
um
if you do then good luck and i hope this
tutorial was helpful
if you have any other
tutorials that you'd like me to do
just hit that subscribe button and write
up a comment and i will try my best to
do it so thanks for watching guys peace